the insane controversial conclusion of
the Blackbeard Pirates vs GARP and Kobe
fight GARP and koozan's full-back story
garp's Bounty and more are revealed in
this epic chapter so make sure to stay
tuned for that show the parking within
and smash that like button if you enjoy
seeing these one piece reviews and want
to keep them coming join the nakama if
you haven't already by subscribing and
hitting that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications so you don't miss
future one piece reviews and updates and
now without further Ado let's jump into
It spoilers and all so this chapter is
called Battleship bag and that title
will be significant and epic as we'll
see later on Ace is on the cover page
which I think was fitting since we had a
moment that definitely reminded me of
Ace and his demise but more on that
later could be some foreboding there so
the chapter itself already starts with
the question Battleship bag and it's
explained ah yes as replacements for
sandbags the ships in the scrapyard are
continuously punched a shocked person
asks by whom and we're told by vice
admiral GARP during his youth it was his
daily routine for many decades even now
love the GARP time and hype building
going on but it makes what's about to
happen this chapter all the more
shocking but for now it's asked why are
there two ships and it's explained the
other one was for the advice Admiral
student former Admiral aokiji what makes
it even crazier and manlier is that the
rule was no hockey or devil fruit
abilities while using the battleship bag
so the strength of these Heroes we're
told was not innate we're used to hockey
and devil fruits now leading to Crazy
Powers but it's so cool and refreshing
to have such restrictions placed on
stuff again and it definitely makes the
feat more impressive imagine replacing a
punching bag with a battleship of all
things we then jump to Pirate Island and
we see that San Juan wolf got blown away
leading people to say GARP is scary and
considering San Juan Wolf's crazy size I
have to agree it said they gotta hurry
and bring him to the surface or he's
gonna suffocate Vasco shot for his part
launches an attack called heavy drinker
hearth fire and GARP uses some NPCs in a
hilarious scene to block the attack
while they scream in pain Pizarro for
his part is using his powers to watch
over everything with the eyes of the
giant skull of the island and he asks
are you playing to destroy this Pirate
Island to GARP others remark that if
Blackbeard finds the island like this he
will kill them at this point GARP looks
Untouchable but as usual things can
suddenly turn 180 in Shonen although
GARP is smiling and they're saying he's
too scary because he's not faltering
from their numbers we can't count on
Garb just taking down Blackbeard's
forces especially if Blackbeard will be
a main and final antagonist of Luffy's
as most of us expect he will be we're
told that the captured citizens and the
injured Marines have all set out to the
Sea while they are trying to carefully
defrost all those who have been frozen
they ask if Captain Kobe is all right
and it looks like a victory they can
depart any time now GARP says alright
we're done here let's go back he adds as
expected of Hachi nosu the Pirates just
keep coming there's no end to them
however just as things look perfect for
the Marines kusan appears in the chapter
and says like I said I can't let you
leave garps on so I like that they added
sond there still showing some respect I
like this teacher student Dynamic I
gotta say it adds a cool aspect to this
fight to no pun intended and although
Peak GARP is beyond legendary usually
age will allow the student to surpass
the teacher and this might be the day
kuzan gets the W it's just unfortunate
that garp's best student turned against
him like this the Marines look cool
standing side by side even if Hal mepo
is saying he should have left because
he's gonna die and this is bad rear
Admiral grew says GARP I'm also the
future of the Marines which is funny he
doesn't want just for Kobe to be getting
all the praise Garb says you still want
to fight kuzan while Kobe tired says
please be careful against the officers
of the Blackbeard Pirates it's good that
they are not underestimating the
Blackbeard Pirates here so if they
accomplish something without Blackbeard
meaning the Blackbeard pirates that
would be all the more impressive for the
Pirates the plan is for the Marines to
run full speed to the Seacoast and to
not die straight forward and it seems
doable and simple enough especially with
GARP on your side however there is yet
another trick like the one pulled on
Odin it's made to look like someone is
in trouble and Kobe Falls for it saying
oh no there's still some kidnapped
citizens left he says I'll save you and
Grouse is the one who calls him an idiot
and says it is a trap Kobe looks in
danger but guard the legend himself acts
quickly and pushes him to safety as he
takes the brunt of the invisible shiru's
attack the hockey infused blade stabs
right through him so remember me
mentioning Ace in the cover art well a
similarly met his end by defending Luffy
and now GARP similarly has been damaged
and perhaps lethally wounded because he
went to save Kobe might be too soon to
say for sure that this is the end of
GARP but if he were to go this may be
how Oda justifies it so Garb didn't
really lose a fair fight but because he
sacrificed himself to save another and
specifically a person who he's called
the future of the Marines as well so in
a way it's him sacrificing himself for
the future reminds me of what shank said
before whatever happens from here on out
though points go to GARP for how after
getting stabbed clean through he goes on
to punch shiru into the ground in Epic
fashion a sweating GARP calls him the
hoodlum from impel down a funny touch as
they realize that he's an invisible
human now they also say he managed to
stab iron GARP which I'm just thinking
in the newspapers that will add a lot of
notoriety to shiru specifically but also
to the Blackbeard pirates in general
it's comment that garp's weakened but he
won't go down that easily Kobe is really
upset saying it's his fault since GARP
protected him GARP says don't be
conceited Kobe shiru was aiming for him
from the start but that's definitely not
how it looked so this might also be GARP
being a good guy to the end and not
wanting to worry Kobe or for Kobe to
blame himself like yes maybe shiru used
Kobe to learn GARP but still it looked
like this was made possible because Kobe
fell for the fake hostage now Kobe
better step up and surpass GARP if GARP
doesn't make it off this silent alive I
know even saying that sounds crazy but
GARP is a member of the old generation
and like it or not one piece is also
about the fall of the old generation and
how the new one Rises and replaces it
Garb himself admitted he's not what he
used to be albeit even if he's still
very impressive and even then Oda gave
him a way of losing outside of a fair
fight as if to pay maximum respect to
the Legend all the Pirates want to take
him down now because he's weakened and
as we're told he's worth three crowns
like an admiral it's three billion
berries which is a hype detail and
definitely makes sense since we know
GARP could have become an admiral
anytime if he wanted to kuzan is the one
who says get out of the way you
weaklings even if you bind both of
garp's arms and legs the likes of you
still won't be able to kill him pretty
hype and I love the respect it seems
this will end with these two we can
mentor and student kuzan prepares to use
the move ice glove against a smiling
Garb as we jump to flashback here a
super young kuzan and GARP are seen
talking GARP definitely looks more like
Dragon here than he does in his old age
kuzan seems to be bothering him to take
him on as a student while GARP is saying
don't steal my freedom go and learn from
the Marine instructors kuzan though says
he's already learned what he could from
them he's aiming for the next level
going above and beyond he begs GARP
please make me your student GARP angrily
says shut up and get lost it's funny it
kind of reminds me of Fight Club you
gotta take some push back and stick it
out before you're accepted and kuzan
clearly did stick it out we jump to them
punching two giant ships and GARP saying
don't use hockey it's hilarious how
young kuzan says I can't use it anyway
ouch so it's crazy to think how far back
that is when koozan couldn't even use
hockey and I like how kuzan's progress
is shown by different sounds and how
their bond is portrayed as growing too
during these panels first kuzan can only
get a weak whack compared to garp's
Giant bam then he evolves into a thud
when GARP says his son became a
revolutionary dammit and this chapter
seems to put the rest the theories that
GARP may have been the dad of Luffy's
mother rather than of dragon then
finally kuzan matches garp's bam with a
bam of his own and it seems that he's
finally caught up to his mentor then we
get when Luffy found out his grandson
was going to become a pirate and he said
he wouldn't allow it and kuzan is just
like bro that's not my problem love to
see GARP just sharing his troubles with
someone like this but through these few
panels Oda really shows us there's a lot
of history between these two even though
GARP was hesitant at first by the end he
wants kusan to eat some snacks with him
kuzlon is the one who's like I'm busy
I'm an admiral you know but GARP insists
saying bring out the T in this way Oda
shows that GARP really dropped his guard
and took kuzan under his wing it's sad
that almost everyone from his son to his
grandson to a student seemed to
eventually end up on the opposing side
we find finally jump back to the present
kuzan says to him looks like he raised
quite the Troublesome enemy while GARP
says you're excommunicated you foolish
student they punch each other and it's
huge this time not holding back with
hockey infused fists so this is
definitely more power than they used on
the battleship bags we see a huge hockey
explosion they are both sent flying and
Kobe Cries Out vice admiral GARP clearly
worried GARP is on the ground not
looking good at all after what could be
a lethal Stab Wound he also received a
punch so strong he's holding his head
and moaning even the that they
thought was safe doesn't seem to be
Pizarro laughs and says your hope of
escaping is Slim you bastards this is
hachinosu if you poke it tons of pirates
will come out you think your ship that
left the coast is safe don't
underestimate the power of the island
island fruit we then see Pizarro he says
when you read the newspaper it's all
Blackbeard this and Blackbeard that we
also want our names to be known as well
the headline for tomorrow's newspaper
will be this the renowned GARP
accompanied by Young Elite troops who
attempted to rescue the hero of the
Marines Kobe were tragically
exterminated at Pirate Island by the
terrifying power of the captain of the
fourth ship of the Blackbeard Pirates of
valo Pizarro we see a giant Arm come out
of the island and it begins dropping
down on the ship in question this is a
complete 180 from how it looked earlier
and now it's seeming like a big
Blackbeard Pirate's Victory without
Blackbeard even having to be present no
less Kobe says no please stop everyone
is there including people who aren't
Marines it's just crazy how Kobe still
doesn't realize that these Pirates don't
care one bit about that GARP almost
looking like he's delivering his final
word says don't lose your composure to
Kobe justice will prevail now this fight
as much as we don't like it may well be
the end for GARP or at least the end for
his fighting in the series Oda made it
fitting of a legend because he's past
his prime sacrificed himself to save
Kobe for the future of the Marines and
was then potentially finished off by his
own student a guy who wouldn't be that
level without him and he put on a great
impressive and hype show in the process
so we'll see but I feel like Kobe is
about to step up that's where my money
is in my view he'll need to step in and
become the legend GARP knows he's
capable of becoming either that or GARP
gives his life making sure that they can
escape and Kobe becomes more legendary
later on spurred on by the memory of
GARP but either way I don't think this
will end with such a perfect victory for
the Blackbeard Pirates as this
Cliffhanger makes it seem and if you
want to know exactly how the Blackbeard
Pirates could do this well against such
a legendary figure and such Elite
Warriors even without their Captain then
you won't want to miss my all Blackbeard
pirates and their powers explained video
where I explain all of that in Greater
detail link on screen right now and I'll
see you there